all right let's try
han
king hong kim hang kim and kim
hey guys
it's good to be here i don't like
carpool lanes i feel like carpool lanes
like society saying hey you know how
you're lonely
yeah do it for longer now
take the long way home think about it
watch people with friends whizzing by
you
wtf society
uh this girl was like my vagina is a 3d
printer i was like that's not even
accurate
okay your room is a 3d printer your
vagina is the tray
it's not even a very good 3d printer it
only prints one thing with lots of
errors
[Applause]
takes nine months to print and the whole
time it's printing it's complaining
wtf women all right that's my time thank
you i'm gonna tell you this immediately
is that
you know
[Music]
[Applause]
thank god he was good because we ran
through every asian stereotype an hour
ago
that was amazing how long have you been
on stand up uh four years where you from
seattle how long you been here uh just
visiting yeah yeah and then you gotta go
back yeah you're hilarious thank you the
3d printer joke's amazing and what i
love about it and this is going to sound
a little bit racist but you're really
like i love hearing an asian talk you
know sort of like i mean you guys are
you guys are good in both obviously
medical fields and technology
and
to hear you know i became racist when
you said obviously bran torino i thought
it was a great
uh is there any chance we can convince
you to uh to move your lips and uh
in uh
you want to say you want to say hello
for a second uh tam fam
no not when they're good
oh jesus mike
you know yeah
i'm not an uncle chang oh
i love that
sure
uh so hang kim tell us something else
interesting about you before you go uh
my name is hans kim that's interesting
very good
well your han's writing is pretty
[ __ ] terrible how about that
piece of [ __ ] are you uh you're from
you're from seattle and you're here for
a little bit are you thinking about
moving down here yeah yeah definitely
enjoying you crazy people
you're hilarious i really hope you do
thanks for coming on the show
there he goes
hans kim follow him on twitter at hans
kim 5. his esses look like jeez the
drawing from ryan